the heck of a game so far to count rest
on Detroit here comes the pitch it's
gobble making a break for home because
hey good evening Francis interrupting
something Jensen we don't work for serif
anymore friends and see that Isaac and I
just think to remember telling you never
to ping my location again except in an
emergency in fact I seem to recall you
adding I really owe you one Pritchard I
need to get a look at some digital files
stored inside the palisade blade most
secure corporate archiving bank in world
there's maybe 50 people out there who
can reprogram it a friend and fellow
hacker who goes by the handle Cheryl Joe
she knows me as nuclear snake why do I
feel like I'm in the middle of a bad
screenplay you've written are you joking
me you a nuclear snake are making a run
for the blades can you reprogram the
security codes there
10 hackers in the world who can access
granted and I'm two of them have you
found the executive suite get this
involves a little more than just typing
on a keyboard Francis I'm sure slaw
mentioned the defenses gorbett servers
are in separate chambers each one is
protected by lasers drones centuries and
more you know try to set me up on him
blade is dead trap and I care for human
life Warren bars
return because you dirty Roma I say go
do it kill yourself
just sitting the chat and I'll do the
rest please you won't regret this
I already do
you